[música]
ajustes Cuando nuestra artillería es muy
golpea bien
entonces tales emociones a veces suceden
especialmente cuando tenemos una semana de mal tiempo
nadie vuela nadie dispara despues
hay dias en que todo esta bien
la artillería comienza a desplegarse
para trabajar de manera muy eficiente Y luego directamente
a veces las emociones están al límite y grito
y la clase estaba tan impresionada
[música]
no pueden hacer tareas militares
llevar a cabo
Si tuvieramos
los tronos del nombramiento militar de la milicia
luchó contra el enemigo con mucha más eficacia
Todos son estacionales y pueden volar.
por la noche y hay casi excluidos allí
hay mucho factor humano en estos drones
factores humanos que no pueden volar
en la lluvia, en la nieve, etc., ¿por qué estamos hablando de
Bakhmut, estamos perdiendo el tiempo porque es invierno por la noche.
estamos largos casi el 50% del tiempo
usamos de manera ineficiente
[música]
pensar que todo lo que vuela es hostil y
la mayoría de las veces, también somos golpeados
pequeño tuvo algunos derribos y
armas anti-drones Es solo que, bueno, no lo es
la ayuda es mas una pena, estas colgando en el campo
de visión y aquí los controles remotos y
empiezas a entender que esto no es un pez
30 km se encuentra muflas se encuentra algunos
un mono en una trinchera debajo de ti y solo un cañón
apunta y trata de derribar su propia
Un dron porque creen que es adivinación
[música]